we have stumbled across another
possible major scam
from the donald trump administration it
turns out
that the trump administration gave a
1.3 billion dollar contract to a company
called
apiject like inject but a
app or maybe it's even api checked like
a
uh like a computer api they gave him uh
he gave them a 1.3 billion dollar
contract to make
covid vaccine syringes the u.s has now
given out about
close to 200 million individual doses
and there are
zero vaccine syringes from
appijek to ap jacked api eject
what the hell is going on we don't know
uh nbc news reporting that a year
after the company was awarded an almost
1.3 billion dollar
contract and loan package to supply
syringes for rolling out the covid19
vaccine
zero syringes have been made
the syringe hasn't even gotten the first
approval it needs from the fda before it
can be manufactured
and the factory that was going to create
650 jobs
to create this as yet unapproved vaccine
has not even been built 1.3 billion
contracts and loans
no factory no approval no syringes
the company api systems corporation
said it was going to be the company that
would make the difference
between a bad rollout and a good rollout
of the coronavirus
vaccines thanks to the biden
administration
the u.s coronavirus vaccine rollout is
going really well
about half of american adults have
received at least one dose
we are close uh we are rapidly getting
into the 30s and soon 40s
in terms of the percentage of americans
that have been fully vaccinated
the need for this syringe from api
eject is now drastically diminished
because we basically have
what we need and it seems as though we
are going to have everything we need to
fully vaccinate the united states
and yet the contracts and the loans are
still there
api was contacted by nbc news they were
asked
what the hell is going on that was not
how the question was asked that's how i
would ask it
they said that they are quote working
with several pharmaceutical companies to
conduct
testing and reviews of the api eject
syringe for covid19 vaccination what
when is this going to happen it's going
to be over before they make any vaccine
syringes
a spokesperson from pfizer
said that even if the api eject syringe
was approved by the fda it would have
no impact on the level of vaccine output
or on the process for distributing
vaccines
by pfizer moderna was asked what about
you
they didn't respond johnson and johnson
uh declined to comment on this
what a it's just listen we don't yet
know the full scope of this there should
be audits
of every single one of these contracts
that the trump administration
gave out if the recipients aren't at a
stage in the process
that they should be or close to actually
being able to deliver what they were
contracted to do
the contracts which i mean do they need
to be canceled
the government should be asking for
money back should lawsuits be filed to
try to
recoup the money that's already been
paid because increasingly it seems that
there is no
uh economic policy or
uh contract or whatever any it all
during the trump administration
seems to link to mostly unsuccessful
uh either outright failures or
incompetency
or participating in grifting
by these companies there was another one
we covered a few months ago and i the
details
are just beyond my my uh recollection
but i think it was a ppe company
that was not even making the ppe but it
was like a middleman of some kind that
the trump administration gave a big
contract to
and they had like no employees they were
a three-month-old con it was just
all grifting grifting grifting um
api checked spokesperson steve hoffman
says when asked about the factory
because remember this was a contract and
loans
to do covet vaccine syringes add a new
factory that would generate 650 jobs
the spokesperson for api jack steve
hoffman was asked by nbc news where's
the factory
and he says that land has been cleared
for construction in north carolina asked
when will the
actual construction begin steve hoffman
was not able to say it seems likely
that the land is not good at the factory
is not going to be built in time for api
eject to participate
in syringe production that will be
materially relevant to the covid vaccine
distribution um it was all a grift it
was all a grift and
ever it's almost every week we find out
if some trump administration grift
or trump campaign grift related to
fundraising
related to contracts related to uh
positions for friends and family of
donald trump it just
never stops i don't expect we will ever
know the full scope of it i'm hopeful
that over time we will learn more and
more about it i don't think we are going
to learn the full scope
let me know what you believe should be
done with these
types of contracts should api eject have
to return the money
what exactly should happen or should we
take the approach of
it's in the past let's let them get away
with the 1.3 billion i tend to think the
answer is no
to that second option let me know what
you think we'll take a quick break i do
want to follow up about what's
in the you know the the biggest
beneficiary of the last 24 hours
48 hours 72 hours of coverage
of the derrick chauvin case and other
things the biggest beneficiary
has been matt gates who has been able to
get a respite
from the focus on him but he is still in
full damage control mode we're going to
talk about that after the break
and we are also hearing about a
republican
that supposedly is moving in the
direction of running for president in
2024.
i will tell you who it is and the
implications right after this short
break
many so-called healthy snacks
don't taste that great they don't fill
you up they don't satisfy a craving
which is why you should check out our
sponsor monk pack
and their keto nut and seed bars
delicious sweet snacks with only a gram
of sugar or less
two to three grams of net carbs and just
150 calories perfect for the keto
or low carb diet or anybody who just
generally tries to eat a low sugar diet
like me
i love the monk pack keto nut and seed
bars
just a great balance of sweet and salty
soft and chewy but with a nice
crunch from the nuts and seeds you can
get
great flavors like caramel not caramel
come on guys
caramel sea salt sea salt dark chocolate
peanut butter dark chocolate that's my
personal favorite they'll give you all
of your money back
if you don't love it go to monkpack.com
the link is down below and you'll get
twenty percent off any of their products
when you use the coupon code pacman